dr falconis selected three hardcover  copies of steve jobs by walter isaacson  for testing with the clockworks the  first copy was placed on the setting  one-to-one the output produced was a  hardcover copy of bill gates by walter  isaacson upon investigation the book was  revealed to be an in-depth biography of  microsoft founder bill gates the next  book copy was placed in the machinery on  the setting fine it produced a dvd that  depicted steve jobs narrating his  biography and the style of an audiobook  the final copy was placed on the setting  very fine the output was a metallic cube  with a single button when the button was  pressed the cube projected a holographic  image of steve jobs which displayed  sapience and an ability to answer  various questions about jobs life and  apple computers